hello everybody.welcome after the coffee
break hope you're enjoying the coffee
if I can see correctly so that's exactly
my dog of the tutorial for the session
like how can we blog or how can we
implement nicer way to convert your
traffic or convert your traffic on your
website or something or any kind of
product page you have through different
kinds of methods and with a special
focus on reinforcement learning and as
you see it's more like in the context of
search so how relevancy and search plays
there so before I dig down since the
Internet is pretty slow here so please
try to go there if you have managed to
come up with the schedule slide I have
put the link there it's just three files
just try to download this so I'm on up
I'm working for Moberly which is the car
verticals for IVA classifieds group
since almost two years now as the senior
data scientist I have been in Germany
like for eight years almost and yeah I
was doing my masters from Max Planck as
a broken you have a small kid I
mentioned that because I do a lot of
reinforcement learning with him on
everyday basis I'll give you some
examples so what we gonna do today so we
talked a bit about information retrieval
that's like not getting into the details
like what exactly it is but more why are
we doing this session today how is it
relevant and how can you implement on
your day to day basis I'll talk about a
very little about a/b test but more into
banded methods anybody heard of banded
methods before cool that's the perfect
audience for me and I'll show you the
variants of different banded methods and
also we will implement one if you want
you can go on with me I have the
notebook already push to get up or I'll
it's very simple it's nothing a data
heavy and will draw some conclusions see
like when to use what so talking off IR
or like information retrieval so an
extremely general level information
retrieval is about how you can order a
set of
documents you have a particular query
and you want to as the black box and he
wants to retrieve or you want to
retrieve a set of documents that's all
it's about but if you see from the time
line basis it's a very very old concept
like back in the 1960s this grand idea
was came into inception and from there
on you see how it developed and
initially it was just text once and then
it was more document-centric and now
it's more into conceptual searches and
stuff like that so if you can or if you
want to have a like a more familiar
names like what does this text search
means or document search means so maybe
this terms would help you for example in
the text search it's basically trying to
touch every word you have in your
documents like throw away all your like
non-stop words or punctuation and stuff
like that and just index the ones which
are meaningful like inverted index
boolean retrieval these are like some of
the I wouldn't go into the details for
this then comes the most structured
information for example you are more
bothered about simulate you have a query
and you want to find out what's the most
relevant document so there comes this
vector model so you you present your
query as a vector and in the same vector
space you represent your documents is
basically a like at like two vectors are
playing with each other like how close
they are depends on the angle between
them simple enough or even tf-idf term
frequency inverted document frequency
just just look it up and in the in the
more recent is like more conceptual
searches for example you can hear of
knowledge graphs you can hear of
semantics there you can hear of
ontologies you can have like graph
traversal algorithms there entity
linking and stuff like that so this is
like the more recent stream of research
in this direction so why am i talking of
this the methodologies are different
like it has evolved over the ages but
what remains still a problem is defining
relevance I come to the site and look
for a like a really nice burger place
versus your friend who is sitting in
that's I don't know New York or
something and looking for a burger place
the results that
friend of course you can just localize
it was a big deal in it but take it to a
different level like you have a
different person I you have a different
way of browsing your internet you have a
number of different factors which makes
you you
so this relevance is personalized this
relevance as a business aspect and also
it has some general aspects so as I
mentioned here like which information is
relevant for you and who is deciding
that and how actually would you even
like what are the criterias that say
okay that's relevant or that's not
relevant so there are like different
strategies for like coming up with a
relevant document for example like you
can say like okay I just want to look
into user relevance if he's gonna click
on a particular item that's a very
simple way of looking into it so you
will see later like here I have to come
up with a definition of relevance and I
try to model the problem and optimize it
against that and that's why I spend some
time on this slide so that you
understand like what exactly or where
can I fit this reinforcement strategy of
you're making them making a webpage to
work or like making your search results
more relevant so what I'm trying to
propose here is not just go for like
okay that's the approach BAM
I'm not gonna change it that's my
criteria for relevance which could be
like a click click rate or it could be
like something more business specific
and I'm not gonna change my part so
that's gonna fixed or would you prefer
something like a strategy which you were
able to modify which which you're able
to adopt depending on your needs or what
I mean is more dynamic way of tackling
this relevance problem so that
completely brings me to this stage where
I can discuss exactly about the
band-aids problem so what are this class
of Mandy's problem so here I'm taking a
bit of detour from my
the classical ayah definitions and
trying to give you introduction so what
I'm planning to do in this whole session
is I give this mini intros into this
concept we see and each we dig a bit
into one of the algorithms and we try to
implement that otherwise I can just jump
into the Python notebook code and then I
mean you don't take anything away with
you so just try to be slowly take it
relaxed so you don't have to have a lot
of coding and stuff like that so a
bandit problem is basically how you can
deal with some kind of dynamic systems
like if you have some variations going
on it's if you have something for
example classical is your webpage you
have results you have people logging in
from different parts of the world they
have different interest and the end goal
is pretty obvious like you want your
visiting people the users to end up with
your to the end of the say like
conversion funnel or however you want to
say you want them to stay on your page
by an article and move on so that
remains kind of same but how can you add
up to this kind of dynamic system so
that's basically the whole gamut of
bandied problems how you deal with those
and adding to that venue from they
really do not know about what's going on
so they just see come react and then
just adapt so that's the cool thing
about it you really don't have to throw
in like a like a like a loads of prior
knowledge well take it with a pinch of
salt for example they would be like
patient bandits as well where you have
you can throw in like priors to it and
this is like a classical reinforcement
learning so this is like exactly when I
was mentioning of my kid so he's like
two and a half years old and he's into
puzzles like each time he puts a block
he looks at my face and I have to
collapse either pop or clap so that
means he did it right and he just moves
on if he's I don't do that it's kind of
rewarding or some kind of that's the
classical example of our universe one
you have to tell the system like hey you
did a good job
go ahead or if you say like no oops it's
a wrong one so it's oh sorry I did
something wrong let's be rectifying the
next step so that's the whole concept of
reinforcement stuff sounds familiar
ok then how is this maybe testing like
everybody does every testing
in on our like day to day basis probably
throw everything JB testing
so the basic difference probably lies in
the like the last point which I
mentioned with me I should have put it
in the first so it's like how this kind
of methodologies deal with the exploit
and explore dilemma what does it mean
so exploitation phase is basically
trying to or like explore an expert's or
like trying to find the ways you can
optimize once you find that way
exploiting is sticking to it sticking to
that and trying to exploit it as much as
it can like hey that's a good guy like
get the juice out of him that's the
exploit concept so the way I be testing
differs from reinforcement is basically
how they're dealt with that could be
very nicely visualized in the diagram
below so on the x-axis you have
basically the weeks as long as when
you're your test is running basically so
week 1 to week 6 let's say it's a ABC
kind of test ok so what you see is a B
and C all this variants are on line
simultaneously good but the bad is on
the y-axis is the basically traffic to
the side it's kind of divided one third
to each of the sections then after the
end of five weeks you find a very nice
statistical significance number some
test is done Optimizely gives you an
awesome report say yeah
option a is the way to go so you stick
to it what happened till one to five you
lost a lot of traffic like you lost all
the traffic to B and C yes you have an
awesome statistically significant number
but yet yours website didn't make money
for us five weeks look into the site I
mean the bandit selection way so it
starts with three different kinds of
algorithms denoted by the same options
different colors well you see is the
best one apparently like the option A it
starts to get better and better and you
see it has a greater share or like it's
trying to it's trying to get more and
more customers to converge to your site
over the weeks and you see within almost
like third week onwards it's kind of
predominantly ruling your site
so that's awesome okay so just to keep
some points in you're just on the back
of your mind so for example short period
of exploration as I mentioned with
exploration and exploit the lemma so a/b
testing has extremely short period of
expressions because they are not really
exploring all the options like together
so like 1/2 like like you look into like
all that 3 like very short time but you
exploit for a long time once you have it
okay
option a is the way to go cool so why to
use Bandits algorithm looking to the
right side that's actually a just just
type this in google so the reporter who
put this it's a article from New York
Post I think you can see from the
quality of the newspaper it's a there
was some gangwar and somebody got killed
anyways so the editor of the paper was
having a dilemma in to some put like
which title to put so that he has the
maximum number of people buying his
newspaper so this was the one and the
second one was like murder victim in
adult entertainment club or something
like that and this has nothing to do
with reinforcement learning but this has
always been used as a classical example
where you try to validate your point
like if you want to have your customers
converge at your site faster or like way
efficiently so you always have to go for
more like a bandits way like you have to
give them an option to choose or like
the let's say a website it has to have
an agent or it has to have like a like a
determining body which can say like ok
now I displayed this kind of titles more
think of it like you for your products
page could be like like your new iPhone
how should the title look like or I
don't know any kind of product so
carrying on with it even more so there
are some like obvious I would just want
to like summarize so the good thing
about this is you can learn about your
data set you can learn about your
traffic as you're going through the test
so which is really cool you can really
automate that's I really love that very
nicely because the moment you see like
something is not working really good or
you can see like okay if I can tweak
something you can really automate
machine learning part as the thing is
gone is life so you can have like a
feedback loop I can show you a like a
prototype architecture diagram how you
can incorporate that in your like a live
system and it's also like a good one in
trying to eliminate the good versus the
bad or even the ugly ones so basically
it explores everything and it just
gradually filters out the the bad guys
out like the low performing candidates
so that's overall extremely helpful so
now I talked a bit details about what
are the bandit algorithms so usually
like there are like the three major ones
so epsilon greedy upper confidence bound
and this Thompson sampling which is we
are going to talk here a bit more
details about the epsilon greedy process
it's extremely simple it's very easy to
understand and the other ones are a bit
more sophisticated under the sense that
it has a bit of Bayesian statistics
playing for example the Thompson
sampling it's been classical like a
Bayesian bandit strategy just to go
through it what is this epsilon and
greedy so it's it has two components one
is the epsilon part where it is trying
to explore and a greedy part which is
the exploiting product like in computer
science greedy is always a kind of
algorithm which is I say it lazy I mean
like it doesn't really like to try out
stuff it just sticks to what it has and
it tries to like exploit that's that
term like exploit it as much as possible
and there is a component called epsilon
I'll just go like show you like what is
this epsilon component and what it is
doing this upper confidence bound or the
UCP wants so this is very okay it really
works very well
like I'm not ordering this by the level
of performance or something I'm just
mentioning them like randomly so this
one this UCP algorithm is more like an
optimistic one so it has a very good
notion about the world and it's a very
like a nice way to see like it's also
coming from our like a person like how
you see it
so you see have a very good notion of
the world and the moment you get
analyzed your notion about the world
breaks and the Oh
oops that was not so nice so it goes
back and tries to like rectify itself
and with the Thomson one is like
classical Bayesian so you start with the
prior so that's that's what I said when
I said like you don't really need like a
extremely wide knowledge about your
setup but it's more like you can set
some kind of prior knowledge it could be
like an absolutely average you can have
start with the uniform distribution like
just a straight line that's the prior
doesn't harm I mean like you can just
read like other papers where they have
later on the different price that's a
different thing but but as you update as
you see more evidences it goes on
updating its first year classical
Bayesian so epsilon greedy algorithm so
I take some time here because I'd really
like to that you understand it because
you would exactly see some parts like
I'll show you lines in the code which
exactly does this part so that's how it
works so you start with uh from your
state let's say like let's say just a
state from your web page or like your
search results page with the epsilon
part it's gonna explore it okay so it's
this could be like usually zero to ten
percent twenty percent and with the
other rest so it's kind of sticking to
it so that's the greedy part of it so it
says okay
eighty percent time I'll choose my best
arm let's let's forget about the arm for
the moment this is the best performing
algorithm and the rest that's a twenty
percent of fifteen percent I try out
other stuff so that's what I now try to
connect the dots like what I just
mentioned few slides back like it tries
to eliminate the good and the bad so
it's sticking to a good one but also
giving it a chance to explore the bad
performing ones who knows maybe there is
a good one who is really doing good and
some region or something like that and
once you have like a like a testable
candidate you can just have like as many
possible possibilities there for example
you can choose one of the different
possibilities in that expiratory part
and you go on updating yourself
so just as a it's very old it's very
obvious for example if you have epsilon
zero that means you're not at all
exploring so you're extremely greedy you
stick to what you have okay and if you
have an epsilon of 1 that means it would
really be super expiratory it's not
gonna stick to what you have found out
so I'll show you like how the results
vary dramatically the very so so so far
so good so you you saw about like a bit
of fire so you saw like different ways
of having a relevance you also had a bit
of entry into the leg Epsilon greedy
algorithm so how can this come together
in the context of search so this is a
kind of proposed architecture let's say
so on the left you have like this is
really very top level like elastic such
cluster or something where you have your
items documents ads whatever indexed you
have a query coming in what you can have
is different kinds of algorithm which I
say here like algorithm to like this one
let's say algorithm 1 3 4 so basically
there are four possibilities of showing
your page or ranking your page that's
what you see here so like you have let's
say a particular timestamp a particular
algorithm and s1 means a search result
page so you what it means like at that
particular time stamp that algorithm
produced that particular search page and
so on and so forth and that is shown to
the user
let's say now the user behaves in some
way with this with this search result
page once you have that kind of explicit
contact point a user likes or dislikes
or could it be some other problem could
it be like it doesn't have to be user it
it could also be like let's say your
your admin or your somebody else who is
even like a seller so who is actually
selling items like I all the stock of
this because we're from eBay whatever
they give some kind of feedback and that
feedback can be incorporated and that's
what this dynamic optimization which I
was talking off in the few slides back
so here you can really adapt and see ok
the moment you see t3 is performing
really nice
you can boost up something or you can
just incorporate that info point into
your feedback loop and that can improve
stuff so now comes multi and bandits so
this is like the classical diagram we
always see so why it's called multi on
basic because a bandit alike who has a
certain probability of choosing
something yes or no let's say the moment
scaled is up for example when you have
many bandits like that so basically like
a lot of algorithms which I just
mentioned so those are basically like
different bandage so each one of them
has a bit of probability of their
success so that's what the multi-armed
concept comes in so I'm coming from a
very top-down approach so I didn't want
to present multi-armed just before I
want to give you like the global picture
okay you have four or five algorithms
they just relate to like your four five
bandits like they're together having
some probability of returning a success
value as I said so success value are we
all like in these terms we always say
it's like a reward function or something
like that very simple let's say one or
zero you can have something else as well
and the overall idea is they say like
how it works so you have this four or
five six machines you go to this casino
you pull a lever you get some coins what
do you do next so that's exactly the
setup so you you you you display your
website you display your search results
from the output from our one algorithm
which algorithm should you show next so
that's exactly where this epsilon greedy
and multi arms is coming into the play
so you say well I am 80% greed 20%
expiratory so you 20% of the time you
look for other arms as well you pull
them as well you see like okay you pull
it you also get a bit more value or it
could also happen let you get way lesser
coins so you fall back to your previous
best and you keep on doing this for many
many number of times so that whole point
of this game or the task is in what
order in how would you pull this arm so
that you can maximize your the coins you
earn from this
machines so to put it in our context so
is like how can you display the search
results page using different kinds of
algorithm or different kinds of
relevance algorithms so that your
maximum convergence is achieved that's
that's exactly the problem statement and
you see like how easily with a very
simple epsilon greedy stuff you can
achieve that so I think okay so this is
just to like give you a clear like so
the band is here in our context is
basically the each algorithm and the
agent is one who is taking this decision
for you one who is doing this automated
game playing for you and so this epsilon
is basically already repeating myself
already now so epsilon is trying to it's
a hybrid of ETA Explorer robot and
exploit a bit so it's it's it's a
mixture of these two approaches now a
bit of math I mean like super simplified
map this is interesting I mean nothing
to worry so what we define is basically
a action value function so which means
which is defined by this Q so it means
like what is your expected long term
Award for choosing like a for taking an
action a from state a so you are in a
particular state which is like let's say
your website comes live and you choose
an action which is like choosing
algorithm 1 like 1 1 1 3 2 2 1 3 2 2 4
so these are your discrete actions what
is the expected gain by using a certain
set of actions so that's exactly defined
by this so let's say for one particular
algorithm so the expected or let's say
like the end of this whole reverse so as
you can see like there are like number
of times you're displaying a search
results page because a lot of users are
coming in so each time you are
displaying something it's basically like
a
like a state you can say and we can show
you later like this this can be repeated
multiple number of times so for one
particular bandit or one particular
algorithm the expected long-term gain is
very simplified like there is no
integral no differentiation it's just
plus - probably classical look into the
first line for the moment like for K
steps for like K was make how many times
a was chosen
let's algorithm 1 how many times did you
choose it let's say 10 times and each
one of those 10 times what about the
rewards yes yes yes zero zero one zero
something like that let's say the reward
is just one and zero so so that's
basically your expected very simple just
add it up like each time you pull the
liver or each time you show that page
just add it up simple just replace K by
K plus 1 so like what what it becomes
nothing fancy like everybody can get
this just replace K by K plus 1 now from
this is like three three lines of just
writing it on your paper from this queue
k plus one stead you can just find like
so this becomes like a more like a
recursive definition of it so to find a
particular state you just need to go to
your previous step and I word for like
the reward for that step and just
subtract your previous state so it's
basically a cumulative reward or
cumulative action which is happening
here now what so if you have a state or
if you have a state function like that
who is your best algorithm simple just
for a is maximum like you have 1 2 3 4
algorithms do this do this computation
for 4 algorithms and just find out who
gives you the maximum Q as simple as
that and that's your basically the
greedy part of it and I can show you
like in a in a short file so like that
would give you the like the like the
greedy part of it so let's Alon part is
still I didn't touch it here so epsilon
part is still like there just say it's a
random part so you can choose any one of
it ok so enough of it let's try to pull
up the notebook if you want you can did
you manage to get the yeah
so I would just propose you be with me
you go through very slowly with the code
you can try it yourself there are very
small places where you can change and
see the differences just a couple of us
prefer to use virtual environment using
Khanda something like that peep is also
fine just that I personally like Conda
better and just activate that
environment and try to install these
dependencies like I PI kernel would be
really helpful because in that case you
can have your environment within your
notebook and Seabourn pandas pretty
standard because I I just love to draw
something okay and I don't see it okay
so going through it very slowly
pretty standard I mean like nothing
fancy here yeah I mean just standard
pandas or some data manipulation like
there is no external data sources I just
created some like mock data data
structures data sources from here so
when we are talking of this SRP or like
the search results page or celebrate
their relevance in context of
search so what we need to do is look
into this later so I just created four
different search results page okay very
simple it has an ID column it is a click
probability column and idler column what
I mentioned before like what is your
target or what is that business need or
the user need you are really optimizing
for what is that you want to be rewarded
for and what is that you don't want to
be rewarded for that's right actually
the dealer comes so dealer is basically
when we are selling an item we want to
have a bit of let's say preference or
like a bit of boost for the so those
guys were like premium account holders
okay and like those who are not premium
account holders they have to be dealt
with differently so it's basically just
a 1 and 0 as you can see it's like
creating like a 1 and 0 for randomly on
this this third column and I define a
max results list length which is
basically a ting 500 yeah so so
basically a search result page which is
having 500 results that's as simple as
that and it has an ID which is basically
just like a cereal like ID let's say
range from 1 to the maximum length 1 to
500 this is the interesting part so what
it does is this is something which you
gonna touch if you really want to have
this in production because this is the
probability which is gonna change let's
see you have a page you have a some
Asian probability of clicking the item
and let's say you find that oh that item
is more clickable you put this in this
feedback loop so that's the item that's
gonna change so keep that in mind so
that's the the trick part or let's say
that's the essential part what I've done
here is basically for that column or
like generate a click probability so
like as I can just show you maybe yeah
something like this it's just I just
pulled up a particular search result
page which has got up some IDs and every
every ID has a click probability of this
and we say like if it's coming from a
dealer yes yes no one so on and so forth
no but you can see that's only this part
of the code
like I just have four search results bit
different by four different click
probabilities what you can see here is
basically the change happens only here
the rest of the part is same so this
means this would always try to return a
value between 0.3 and 1 whereas this one
this one would try to give you like a
value from 0 to 1 and this is like a
different one like 1 0 1 2 6 so what I'm
doing is I'm kind of forcing the
different search results based to
generate different types of click
probability 1 intentionally a bit higher
so that means those items produced by
that page are just more clickable let's
say that way how it okay and what I do
here is basically get this data frame
get this panda's data frame and simply
try to find out like if it's a dealer so
that's exactly the the thing which is up
to you what does showing that page mean
to you where here I have defined like
okay if I showed that kind of a page the
return on the score from that page is
something like how click abilities in
which rank it occurs so that's why you
have divided by the ID so further you go
down the rank so guy let's say so the
first one how its computed is basically
this value divided by 1 into 1 whereas
if you go this guy it's like this
divided by 2 because even if it's a
higher probability the fact that it's
operating at rank 2 you just smoothen it
or you just decay it that's a not smooth
and decayed you can have different decay
functions you can have like exponential
decays and stuff like that it's very
simple like I just want to have like
from this page like what is the value
generated by that in terms of click and
you multiply with dealer because anybody
who is not a dealer zero I just
multiplied this this column so it gives
no value so that's very simple if I'll
just work with you so you take the click
probability product with the dealer so
whenever it's a zero
wholesome is basically it has like a
zero contribution divided by the rank so
it's just decays it and you divide by
the sum of the dealer so if I just want
to normalize by the number of dealers
that webpage is having why a plus one if
it doesn't have a dealer I don't want to
have a divided by zero simple as that
you get a score return that so you get
like a score generated by rank and and
you repeat that for like two hundred
times so basically you create a lot of
srp count so basically like I'm
generating a lot of webpages lot of
search results page and so what's
interesting is once you generate that
you can try to see like what is the so
this was like the the part where I
mentioned like I made some some
probabilities bit higher and that's what
you see exactly
[Music]
just to give you overall picture so like
under x-axis you have the algorithmic
choices and on the left you have the
values so you see the algorithm one
which is on purpose I made it like to
have more clickable items so strength
higher like it's like the distribution
of the whole thing median values kind of
there three is way lower so we gonna
throw in this this kind of algorithm or
just recollect bandits to an agent and
the agent would try to find out who is
the best that's that's the whole goal of
this exercise and and if you just try to
go by the different is happy so you saw
like I'm generating a lot of pages such
like that so each time I say like okay
give me four pages from different
algorithms I do it 200 times and I just
plot that so you see this this blue
curve like the from algorithm it's more
like having like often you see it's kind
of ranked a bit higher so it's having
more value in general that's how I
macht that data set okay now know what I
do is for each algorithm I try to find
like a like a mean value of it which is
exactly what you show what I showed in
in in this step so I just get like okay
on an average or the median value for
this is this kind of a return so I just
take it and it's just like a very small
cute data frame you just having these
four values okay why do I need that
because I need to initialize my bandits
with some initial probability so one
thing which I really missed sorry for
that is like whenever you pull an arm
you actually have like a probability or
like a say that okay this has this much
chance of giving you something okay so
that's the knowledge you actually have
so here what I do is just initiate like
a set of Bandit probabilities with just
four values which is take this value
like the medium value and just normalize
it so what you get is something like
this so as you see the algorithm one has
like thirty five point eight percent
chance of it's a success or being having
more clicks and so on and so forth and
and the order is exactly the same as you
saw here like this kind of a you thing
okay what I define more I'd like the
number of bandits simple there are four
in this case I just say like the length
or you can just find it from the other
size of the data frame as well anything
works so episodes and experiments so the
episode is basically the times you play
it out so this kind of algorithm so it's
not like you do like one time you pull
the lever okay wow I have everything I
know everything about this for arms or
the for algorithms so you have to keep
doing it and it emerges you know in a
certain number of play out so we often
call it like episodes or play out so
like the number of times you basically
display that page to an end user
experiment you do the same exercise this
many number of times so it's not like
you run this whole simulation once
but probably lay quite number of times
because this just to average out and see
like how it really pays off like over a
large number of drawers so that's always
like a case with this kind of random
trials as you might recollect from your
36 class like it it gives you a better
sense of the distribution this is like
some fancy stuff which you can I just
wanted to if you want to save a figure
or something that just skip it for the
moment okay here comes the interesting
part so two components bandit and agents
right so it's just a very small plus
which is just abandoned which I say like
how many bandits are there and what are
their probabilities
that's I just initiate that in its
constructor and let's go line by line
with this one so get reward so given a
bandit I say like I take an action what
is my reward so it's very simple I just
have a like a random reward generated so
which is like a zero to one and just
look into this lines like if if the
probability for that action so funny
when I say action here so it means like
for this bandit is asking this class to
say like okay what is the reward if I
choose algorithm 3 what is the reward if
I choose algorithm for so action is
basically imagine like one of the four
algorithms which I just showed you once
you have that it's very simple just
check the random value if it's less than
zero less than that you just set it to 1
or else it's zero so I say like okay so
to say it in other words like there is a
number and then you say look actually it
should I choose number three and he said
okay no the random value is quite low so
you don't choose it go ahead
this could be modified you could be more
complicated is just to give an
impression just to throw like throw a
reward like yes no for the next choice
that's it this this really doesn't make
a difference like a huge difference but
you can really make it more complicated
because you might wonder like okay it's
a random value so what's going on here
but not to worry here it's just giving a
reward sense to the next step
it now is the agent so agent is
basically the guy who is orchestrating
the whole thing okay
again it's I have written it here so
this is exactly the formula you saw here
that's why hey that's why I took this
time to write this formula so it's
basically just update yourself with the
same it's very similar to like we have a
lot of gradient descent discussions and
in the morning it's very similar to that
you just take the n minus one at state
and you just update your net state with
it so simultaneous gradient descent
algorithm works exactly like that here
so you just um define an epsilon so we
are implementing an epsilon greedy
algorithm here so we have an epsilon
value here and some K and Q so basically
this Q is the thing which you can update
let's go here and that's the line that's
it so you just take an action you just
update your counter so like this is the
K plus 1 you make it k plus 1 and that's
it when you add to your like the next
value is like the previous one plus
equals to is like this equals to this so
it's like similar to writing like x
equals to 1 so this means is equals to x
equals x plus 1 so that's the way it is
so that's this operator is doing
basically you try to update your next
state with your previous value and also
you have the reward so you see like
updating that particular action with
that reward you I'll show you like how
this r1 is coming from where and how
this action is being pushed here and now
you have everything and you just need to
like do the explore part of it so that's
weakly like choosing action using an
epsilon greedy agent so you choose a
random value and you just say like okay
is my
absolute value like less than that so if
I choose a very less epsilon value you
try to not explore so much but it just
go to the greedy approach but if it's
like a decent value it tries to get into
this law you can also override it where
you can say by setting it to true saying
like okay you always explore so that's
actually the expiratory part where well
you can imagine like here nothing fancy
you have like 10% chance you just pick
any just pick any algorithm that's it
the interesting part is basically here
so this part is exactly this part so you
out of all your updates all your Q
actions you just take the index or so
index is basically from for for
algorithms you have 0 1 2 3 you take
that index which is giving you the
maximum reward that's exactly where you
and that's the fancy way of doing this
so you just take the greedy action so
you tell like ok that's my guy that's
the algorithm whom I should choose next
so this is like the greedy part of it
you have everything now you have all the
things in place now we define our
experiment so this is just like like
bringing the 3/4 stuff together you
initiate like maybe just here so there
is a simulation step so maybe that
starts from here so you I defined you I
showed you the bandit bandit
probabilities which is like from the
mean valve in values I just computed I
initiate a bandit and I initiate a agent
I pass that bandit and I pass on Epsilon
as simple as that now let's go back and
so you already saw this bandit an agent
now I take that bandit and that agent
and I said ok let's experiment now so
this experiment basically takes like
these two components and let's see what
happens here exactly so giving an agent
and some bandits how does the playoffs
occur across each episode so like each
time you're showing the page what is it
actually choosing what what which
algorithm is actually it's playing out
step one you have a agent is that okay
just using I will choose choose for me
something choose an action
here's Maksim if you just want to
recollect was this choose action was is
this this part which I just explained so
you with a certain epsilon either you go
the greedy way or the epsilon way if
there is no current burst it just select
something maximum probably the first one
it doesn't matter I have an action now
what to do next what is my reward it's
very logical see it like this just three
step okay I got an action what is my
reward so you go to the Bandidos okay
we'll give me my reward second this this
this one which I mentioned like for
choosing that action if I have it give
me a one yes good good job otherwise a
zero well I have my reward
okay now in to update my queue status so
for that action what is my reward I got
like cumulatively and you go on adding
that and you just put it into this two
variables so what was the set of
algorithms chosen in sequence and what
was the exact rewards I had and you just
return that value and if you see here
yeah that's it this is just like to
print out something to see like the
progress to the experiment so what i'm
doing here is doing this repeating this
play out step quite number of times so I
just want don't want to like have like
value of like a 1 here I like to play it
just one on once but like do it several
times to see that it's really like the
best algorithm is the winner
mmm okay this is just some like adding
and subtracting and finding the mean
putting it in a list this is not the
interesting part and I just want to have
an average value so okay let's let's run
this
okay let's try
so where am i different
so what i'm doing here is let's do the
one easier way so i just want to change
my epsilon from like five what does it
mean like i'm not at all exploratory
which is means epsilon of zero to like
0.5 meaning i'm like i'm gonna explore
fifty percent of the time and then i'll
just change it and show you like from if
i would really make the epsilon very
high meaning like i'm very exploratory
the results how the very and i run this
so it says like a guy it's like four
bandits with epsilon zero
so some words here so epsilon zero what
does it mean just go back here just very
very epsilon of zero you always take the
best term I'm super lazy let's say I'm
extremely greedy I found one good one
I'm not gonna look anywhere else I'm
gonna stick to that and that's exactly
what's happening
after a few play outs on the x-axis you
see like SRP players which means like
search results page how they are
displayed after a few displays oh well
algorithm one is super good I'm never
gonna explore anything else it just
sticks to it forever
that's epsilon zero now comes with a
point one exploration which means like
ten percent so I'm sticking with the
good but I'm also giving myself or the
agent is giving a chance given a chance
to to explore other opportunities as
well now you see some some nice things
happening so you see like the good ones
emerging and the bad ones like the
inferior ones kind of filtering out
that's exactly what I meant by worse
versus the good ones I go on increasing
the epsilon you can see in the title of
the image so the difference you have to
observe in this initial phases like
where the how sooner it kind of finds
that page so here you see like 10 to the
power 1 so like approximately 10 pages
here I guess it's bit sooner and things
like that here it has a bit of confusion
it's around like less than 10 pages 10
play out so you have some numbers and I
think it's oh yeah so it's still 0.4 now
I'm gonna change this change the epsilon
values to 2 let's say
yes
yes exactly
just one yeah but let's say exactly like
that's the whole panic if you don't want
to like play just once you have to run
it like several times like this is not
yet in production so probably there has
to be like a better way of doing it of
course like I cannot afford to have like
multiple simulations refresh or page so
could be like I can do some offline
stuff from our like historical search
results page to see like okay what made
sense and then stick with some
particular epsilon value so it could be
pre trained in that sense I mean as your
right I mean like just showing it once
you just stick to one and just play it
out that way
okay and what I wanted to show was okay
I wanted to change let's say make it
really high so that means like very
exploratory
here it still kind of makes sense but
you see like like as we increase this
expiratory aspect of it it starts
getting like lesser and lesser evident I
mean because now you're kind of really
picking anything at random at any point
of time so you're not sticking to any
greedy approach and you see like the
difference gets smaller and smaller like
after some point of time you it's just
like a coin toss it's just like say four
four four sided dice roll as good as
that so yeah that was the main part of
it I mean this is the first like it's
like a side expiratory task for me like
when I was working at this place too
because we had some undergoing
discussions about how to display how to
make optimal search and relevant stuff
like so I try to like have a like a
weekend project on this to see like how
does it make sense but yes there are
like really open points and if you're
really working into this search area
like I'd be more than happy to discuss
this with you
like exactly as he asked like in
practice like how would this be
optimally designed like how can you
really play out the most efficient way
in the quickest milliseconds possible
these are like some add-on code which we
just try to see there okay the fact that
I choose algorithm one as the winner so
what would be my like eventual layout so
what is my overall gain I'm getting so
you can go through the code you can just
run this if you just say like okay the
fact that I'm playing out so many times
and sticking to an algorithm on which
emerges as the winner so you can expect
like like I would jump in this RP score
so this is our P score is that that find
two lines of code which I showed in the
beginning like defining the the return
from showing that SRP page so that kind
of Rises and it sticks to it so because
you are now playing out that more often
you're sticking to that choice and
exactly and that kind
of well I have some more okay so yeah
now this is an alternative approach when
I started with the discussion or the
this presentation I said okay there is
no just unique way of doing it so this
is just like a different strategy of
solving this problem I just want to
propose that idea here so when to choose
what like because I know most of you are
like very familiar with a/b test and
stuff like that so to to wrap up just
carry home with yourself this this
simple message which is if you really
want to have strong statistical
reasoning behind your choice if you
really want to have like concrete
evidence like okay I choose a red button
over a blue button because a B test is
the way to go
because that's not really the job of I
wouldn't say it's not the job of but it
just takes too long because if you stay
here on the right-hand side to have like
enough evidence for example I can I can
rephrase this part so let's say you have
multiple variants and you just showed
you like algorithm for is bad yeah okay
take it with a pinch of salt in the
sense we didn't really explore for a
long long period of time to have an
evidence in the sense like four is
really really bad that's what a B test
would do because we just try and collect
evidences events clicks whatever from
different variants and they would
compute this statistical significance
from those behavior however if you
really want to have faster convergence
you don't really care if it's good bad
or ugly you really want to have people
just convert because that that's a
newspaper that editor wanted his papers
to be sold in the next day morning you
don't have time for every test you want
you have a new BMW or new Christmas item
on the site you want people to buy it
because the dealer has really is a high
high profile dealer you don't have time
for a beta so I can just play it out
they would converge you can try out
different algorithms they're like okay
and suit your needs a suit your problem
like problem or like the
the target question and in such a
fashion it helps so yeah that's what I
exactly meant like think of your use
case where it fits you if there's a
possible keep that graph in mind of
course like is Google doing it this way
is a whole Erie and X doing it this way
maybe may not be I don't know they have
different like they're known for the
thing they are like learning to rank
models you can you can challenge things
okay they're definitely like awesome
rank morale learning to rank models
where you can throw in like n number of
variables you can just train your query
and document as a the joint feature
variable and then you can predict
something true probably but often
sometimes you can have scenarios where
it's just not possible you might not
have all the aspects of the data you
just have few ranking functions to play
around with you have few alternatives to
play around with and you really don't
know which works best in which case so
probably give it a thought it could be a
good option yeah that's more or less I
finished quite before I mean quite
preemptively like I still have 30
minutes
I dip celebrity but you need evidences
right to update your posterior you need
more and more evidence as the better you
get yes it's exactly that there is no
like theoretically they're not
theoretically let's say the things
they're doing are not really extremely
different like epsilon is as a like I
stick to it I am exploring but with the
Bayesian approach it's like updating as
it sees exactly you can do it so and
that's the when I was on that slide I
said if saloon really actually that
comes on something works really good
really really good just for the sake of
these and like just to get this concept
across absolute beauty is just very easy
to show and stuff like that I'm pretty
sure you can find some implementation
there for this for the Bandit I guess
there is not such library but for
reinforcement learning there are like
tents a few libraries and stuff like
that you can look into it yeah just for
the sake of completion we are hiring
people we have our booth please come
over and say yes hello and we have
multiple job openings and yeah great for
thanks for being a great audience
[Applause]